should go back to hiding behind those
blue curtains all right horowitz's
report on coma is separate from the
larger one of the do jays handling of
the trump russia probe but it's still
expected to judge the former FBI
director quite harshly here to respond
to this bombshell our is gonna be out is
Rudy Giuliani a former New York City
Mayor Trump's personal attorney Rudy we
didn't previously know Horowitz was
blocking out a separate report just on
call me like he had that big book launch
remember so maybe he can do it another
book tour I couldn't do a report tour on
the report well I don't want to oversell
it cuz I don't know I just think I know
Horowitz not personally but I know he
was an assistant US attorney and a good
one and I hired Jim Comey so I think I
know Jim Comey you're responsible so I
am well the president always reminds me
I'm responsible for Comey but
exceedingly the reality is that commies
conduct was outrageous for a prosecutor
it any any decent project prosecutor
will be bouncing off the walls starting
with the completely fixed Hillary
Clinton investigation that was a sellout
a fix from the day one there's a
disgrace
I don't think Jaggu Hoover ever did that
I think if you take us through the steel
affidavit a skill dossier and the lying
about a validated skilled dossier was
validated and putting his name down
under oath I mean that's straight-out
purge all the FISA Court gets this act
like he and I put people in jail for
much less than them it's an application
that does not reveal that the dossier
was funded by the president's opponent
like material fact in that Pfizer I was
there for the beginning of the FISA
Court and showed to Jennifer was one of
the lawyers on the FISA Court one of the
first and that's a sacred duty because
nobody gets to respond I did hundreds of
affidavits for regular wiretaps for
mafia people
well somebody challenged those
eventually in court but when I did a
Pfizer affidavit nobody ever got to see
it
it was my response really to be honest
with the court that man lied straight
out lie no way he didn't know that the
steel dossier was a big phony piece of
junk you read the first three pages if
you're a professional this is like
National Enquirer wanted it to be true
Rudy and that's why he went and briefed
like president
spoke the president ultimately Kanab
slater when he knows it's not true
he goes and tells it to the president
like it's real that's pure J Edgar
Hoover that man I got something on your
crime here or is it a well series of
unethical how about a simple one the
signature on the Pfizer affidavit is a
crime what did how is that a crime it's
a crime because it's a it's a full
statement under oath he signed on a
penalty of perjury that means I mean
something perjury it's a five-year
statute
how many people did Comey put in jail
for a single perjury Martha Stewart
should even commit perjury she made a
full statement to the eff what about the
leak of the dr. snow it had to go to
jail what about Sally she go to jail
three times for the memo to the file his
own file he always goes to the city we
can write some memos and then he gives
it to his pal gets through the New York
Times the weekend it's a week the
weekend could be more unethical than
that Neely then then illegal I think
there was a conspiracy however to frame
drop I think this was a conspiracy to
frame Trump and I think it goes which
players were well I can't name them yet
because they're not identified but this
is a counterintelligence conspiracy that
started with feeding information a
Papadopoulos and having faba dollars
regurgitated to Australian ambassador
involved the Ukraine that involved Italy
you know Valve UK involved Australia
bare minimum who could do that but
somebody in the CEO CIA Comey couldn't
actually do that Comey could know about
it
Comey could be part of it Comey could be
a player in it but there's somebody else
was a brainchild of this Comey played
his part as a lawyer to the court and
there's no confusion about a crime
there's nothing clearer then you are
swearing under penalties of perjury
named James Comey paragraphs such and
such total lie
go to jail he's actually tweeted out
last night might have missed this and he
said he's gonna keep speaking out
against the president he said I told a
former colleague that I'm tired of being
a trump critic he responded with
encouraging words that apply to all of
us
where you see wrong inequality or
injustice speak out because this is your
country he's right
keep speaking out Oh James Park she's
like hilarious James Cardinal Comey
oh my god James Cardinal call me what a
phony I know what a total phony he will
have plenty of opportunities three four
years in a federal prison writing about
all this and then we can read about all
these critters have a lot of time one
time to reflect explain further if you
don't get to commit perjury and get away
with it not if you put people in jail
for perjury and not if you put people
what the I G's role is it he can't
indict the IG cannot indict he can
recommend various actions but it's
different from mine practice playing
that very cool I think I think what he
is basically an internal monitor so he's
like the person that works for a company
that tells you how bad your people are
in your company but you can't indict
anybody he's an honorable it's been
there for about 35 years but he can
refer for prosecutors that he's already
referred call me for prosecution once Oh
seems to me like Horowitz wanted a
prosecutor that first time you don't
refer for prosecution we don't the guy
prosecuted and I think bill Barr gave
him a pass I don't think he gets a
second pass I'm skeptical I think I know
how can credibly stand up in court and
prosecute somebody else for perjury if
you don't prosecute him for perjury you
lose all credibility Rudi it's great to
see you for being here in DC